[Music]  you got gwenyth paltrow shows off her  silly side with pal Derek Blasberg and a  for everyone very well Vanity Fair's  Blasberg and the goop guru pranked some  unsuspecting spa treatment seekers by  pretending to be facialist when also  posed as a waitress and get this nobody  noticed her at first that's good did you  did you see that that was lesson learned  pay attention to those customer service  people the actress also posed as a  terrible spray tanner you can see the  hilarious prank the affinity fair of  course when has her own line of  legitimate beauty products here's what  she told ET was very important to me no  I'm very into health and wellness  [Music]  you